congrats to you all this is a major day
and emotional day
baba mall brings you out this is one of
my favorite artists for a long time i
don't did anybody know about that was
that announced at all
oh my goodness i just saw the video i
wanted to be there so bad
talk about that you come out to baba
mall you end with this big emotional hug
you guys are
a family are you not
yeah i mean
something about the alchemy that ryan
coogler puts together that
and i think it starts at the top right
he sets a certain tone
uh certain culture on set that we're
it's all hands on deck you know it's
team work it's familial it's it's it's
intimate
and you go kind of through the fire
together and lord there you know there
were fires
and so it brings us all together and
then to see the fruits of our labor
out there and they're bigger than any of
us you know we are all little little
pieces of the puzzle but then to see it
all together it's very very moving and
to see what it means to an audience like
there's something visceral about this
particular story that um yeah just
brings us to tears yeah it's exceptional
you want to comment on that
it's definitely a family it was a family
from the very beginning um
and
the family has extended a little bit you
know we have new members we have new
members
um but like lupita said it's it's a
great alignment of souls and people who
really care and people who really want
to honor um the legacy you know that we
are trying to carry on of of of what
chadwick started and and we're really
really just grateful to have each other
beautifully said and
newbie
i love it it's they
they receive all of us the new
like like family and it feels so good
and you feel comfortable and you feel
you know the people is backing you and
i don't know it's
pretty good
at the end of the teaser we see a
another panther being released a panther
claw how how does the franchise move
forward honoring chadwick of course but
without him what can you tell me about
moving forward
that we do it yes we do move forward we
do it
well
amen we do it with love and care and
style and style yeah
a little bit of
dance to it
was it special being backstage with all
the other marvel actors too
yeah that is always special
you know it's kind of like
marvel school yeah reunion yeah always a
reunion yeah listen congrats you guys
onwards and upwards and enjoy your comic
con we appreciate you all stopping by
and welcome welcome to the party
[Music]